I stole my wife's car
think she'll notice the fate of the
furious is directed by F gary Gray who
also directed the Italian job which also
starred Charlize Theron and Jason
Statham and II directed a man apart
which had Vin Diesel in it so it's
pretty much fate that he would make a
fast and furious movie at some point and
after his success with that
excellent Straight Outta Compton I was
pretty excited to see what he was gonna
do with this movie I'm a fan of this
franchise I know that these films are
supposed to be completely over the top
and that's what I want to see when I go
see a Fast & Furious movie and in this
film Dom goes rogue he goes against his
team because Charlize Theron has got him
by the balls we don't exactly know why
we just know that she has some serious
beef on him and for that reason he's
starting to steal nuclear weapons and
EMP devices and we don't know what's
going on everything about the fate in
the Furious is completely ridiculous and
that's exactly how I like it
I want these movies to be over the top I
want them to be absurd in this film
Charlize Theron hacks into a thousand
cars in a city and sends them all
hurtling after our favorite team of
mercenary they're falling from the sky
there's like hundreds of them Tyreese
surfing on a card or on ice I mean what
more could you possibly ask for
if you go to this film expecting a
serious entertainment if you go to the
state and the Furious the 8th Fast and
the Furious movie expecting it to be a
wonderment of screenwriting this is not
a good idea don't go to this movie the
best way that you can judge whether or
not you're going to enjoy this eighth
installment the franchise is to measure
how long the stick is that's up your
butt if it's not too long it's kind of
like a little stick and you know it's
just kind of in there and you're just a
little jaded well then you'll probably
enjoy yourself but if you got a big old
branch stuck up there just don't even go
because you're just going to be like
that would never happen
that's implausible that doesn't make
sense why am i watching this movie
Vin Diesel keeps saying things in the
exact same way over and over again and
every once in a while he just explodes
and goes my fault Charlize Theron is
perfectly acceptable as a Bond villain
with blonde hair extensions and if you
look at her performance from that
perspective you're going to have a great
time the best part of this movie easily
by far and my favorite part of this
movie is the chemistry or not chemistry
between Jason Statham and the rock these
guys are mortal enemies and they get put
in jail together and every single scene
with them I loved and this film had a
hard job it had to make Jason Statham's
character likeable Jason Statham himself
is likable he's one of the most likable
action stars out there but his character
is kind of a murder his horrible person
so to get him included on the team they
went the route of giving a little infant
to care for and so in that way they open
up the doors to kind of make you see him
more as a human and the scene in this
film that absolutely lets you know that
you are watching a completely idiotic
film that knows it involves Jason
Statham and that infant and a nice
little wave I'm telling you I think I
annoyed the people who are sitting
around me because I screeched with
laughter so loud this movie entertained
me okay I don't go too fast mysterious
movies expecting anything other than a
lot of really loud car chases and action
and Vin Diesel with his raspy voice and
if he doesn't start talking about family
and how you never turn your back on
family well then I would leave
disappointed I expect every single one
of these movies to have long overdrawn
cheesy monologues about family and then
a whole bunch of like superhero moments
where they're driving cars through the
air and absolutely insane things are
happening that's what I want
ask your issues with the film the pacing
of the second act really drag for me
there's a lot of sit down meetings with
Kurt Russell and Scott Eastwood where
they're all trying to plan what they're
going to do about DOM and his rebellion
against the team and
goes on and on there's all this talk
about the god I that device that can
find anything anywhere anyone and I'm
just like can we just get two cars
falling out of the sky please let's get
to the cars falling out of the sky and
of course with every Fast and the
Furious movie there's always a moment
where you're just like no no but that's
again what I want like for some reason
there's this one series of movies that's
extremely popular where I do not care if
insane things happen The Fast and the
Furious movies ever since the 5th one
have been the best bad movies that
Hollywood is producing at a large
massive big-budget scale is it as good
as fives know I still think 5 is the
best I think 6 might be a tad better too
but I do actually like this one more
than 7 I'm going to give fate of the
Furious of B and just so you know and it
sucks that I have to say this but since
there are so many YouTube channels who
have done sponsorships with cars before
which is something that I just know this
really is my wife's car and this is not
a sponsored video I just thought this
would be fun to do it like this because
cars fast mysterious speaking of my wife
I should probably get home soon because
she'll know if the car was gone for too
long she had like a radar for this so I
better get going
[Applause]
[Music]
no geese no no damn it Canadian geese
are crossing in front of the car right
now I wish I could show you